OK.
Today we are going to talk
about a very interesting
algorithm called Quicksort --
-- which was invented by Tony
Hoare in 1962.
And it has ended up being a
really interesting algorithm
from many points of view.
And because of that,
it turns out today's lecture is
going to be both hard and fast.
If you see the person next to
you sleeping,
you will want to say let's get
going.
It's a divide-and-conquer
algorithm.
And it sorts,
as they say,
in place, meaning that it just
rearranged the elements where
they are.
That is like insertion sort
rearranges elements where they
are.
Mergesort does not.
Mergesort requires extra
storage in order to do the merge
operation.
To merge in linear time and
place, it doesn't merge in place
in linear time.
It doesn't do it just by
rearranging.
It is nice because it is in
place, so that means that it is
fairly efficient in its use of
storage.
And it also happens to be very
practical if you tune it a bit.
The basic algorithm turns out,
if you just implement that,
it's not necessarily that
efficient.
But if what you do was then do
the standard kinds of things you
do to goose up the runtime of
something, and we'll talk a
little about what those things
are, then it can be very,
very practical.
So, it uses divide-and-conquer
paradigm.
First step is divide.
And to do this basically it
does it by partitioning.
So, it partitions the input
array into two subarrays around
an element we call the pivot --
-- such that elements in the
lower subarray are less than or
equal to x, are less than or
equal to elements in the upper
subarray.
If we draw a picture of the
input array, this partition step
basically takes some element x
and everything over here is less
than or equal to x after the
partition step and everything
over here is greater than or
equal to x.
And so now the conquer step is
pretty easy.
You just recursively sort the
two subarrays.
So, I recursively sort the
elements less than or equal to
x, I recursively sort the
elements greater than or equal
to x.
And then combine is then just
trivial.
Because once I have sorted the
things less than or equal to x,
then sorted the things greater
than or equal to x,
the whole thing is sorted.
So, there is nothing to do
really for the combine.
The key step in quicksort is
this partition step.
That is the thing that does all
of the work.
And so you can view quicksort
of just as recursive
partitioning.
That's all it is.
Just as mergesort was recursive
merging, quicksort sort of goes
the other way around and does
recursive partitioning.
The key is the linear time,
by which I mean theta n,
partitioning subroutine.
And here are some pseudocode
for it.
This is actually slightly
different from the book.
The book has one.
In fact, there is a nice
problem in the book that has
even a different one,
but they are all basically the
same idea.
Partition (A,
p, q).
And what we are looking at,
at this step of the recursion,
is the subarray A from p to q.
And basically we pick a pivot,
which is we are going to just
pick as the first element of the
array A of p.
And the book,
just for your information,
uses A of q.
I use A of p.
It doesn't really matter.
And then we set an index to p
and then we have a loop.
This is the code.
Basically the structure of it
is a for loop with an "if"
statement in the middle.
And so the structure of the
algorithm of this partitioning
step looks as follows.
We set the pivot to be the
first element.
Here is p and here is q.
This is going to be our
invariant for the loop.
And, at any time during the
execution of a loop,
I essentially have some values
up to i which are already less
than or equal to x and then some
values that end at j minus 1
that are greater than or equal
to x.
And then I don't know about the
rest.
And so we start out with i
equal to p and j equal to p plus
1.
It starts out at p plus 1 so
that everything is unknown
except for x here.
And then the idea is that it is
going to preserve this
invariant.
And the way it does it is,
as we go through the loop,
it looks at a of j and says is
it greater than or equal to x?
Sorry, is it less than or equal
to x?
If it is greater than or equal
to x it does nothing,
because what can happen?
If this is greater than or
equal to x, essentially it just
goes to the next iterational
loop which moves this boundary
and the invariant is satisfied.
Does everybody see that?
Yeah, OK.
But if it is less than or equal
to x, I have got a problem if I
want to maintain the invariant
if this next element is less
than or equal to x.
And so what it does then is it
says oh, let me just move this
boundary and swap this element
here, which is greater than or
equal to x, with this one here
that is less than or equal to x,
thereby increasing the size of
this subarray and then the
invariant is satisfied again.
It is a fairly simple
algorithm.
And it is actually a very tight
and easy algorithm.
That is one reason that this is
such a great piece of code
because it is very efficient.
Now, in principle,
the running time for this on n
elements is order n.
Because I am basically just
going through the n elements and
just doing a constant amount of
work and then just a constant
amount of work outside.
This is a clever piece of code.
In fact, in principle partition
is easy, right?
If I weren't worrying about
doing it in place,
it is really a pretty easy
thing to do.
I take an element and just
compare every other element with
it.
I throw one into one bin and
one into the other.
That is clearly linear time.
But often what you find is that
just because you can do it that
way theoretically doesn't mean
that that is going to end up
giving you good code.
And this is a nice piece of
code that allows you to do it in
place.
And that is one reason why this
is a particularly good
algorithm, because the constants
are good.
So, yes, when we do asymptotic
analysis we tend to ignore the
constants, but when you're
actually building code you care
about the constants.
But first you care much more
than just about the constants,
is whether overall it is going
to be a fast algorithm.
Let's go through an example of
this, I guess I will do it over
here, just so we get the gist.
Here is a sample array that I
have created out of hallcloth.
And here we are going to set x,
the pivot, to be 6.
Let's look to see how this
algorithm works.
So, i starts out here and j
starts out here if we
initialize.
And what we do is start
scanning right,
essentially that code is
scanning right until it gets
something which is less than or
equal to the pivot.
It keeps going here until it
finds, j keeps incrementing
until it finds something that is
less than or equal to the pivot.
And, in that case,
it is the number 5.
Then it says we will swap these
two things.
And it does that and we get 6,
5, 13, 10, 8,
3, 2, 11.
And meanwhile now i gets
incremented and j continues
where it left off.
And so now we keep scanning
right until we get to something
that is less than or equal to
the pivot.
In this case it is 3.
We swap 3 and 5 and get 6,
3, etc.
And now, at this step we
increment i, we start j out
here.
And in this case,
right off the bat,
we have something which is less
than or equal to x,
so we swap these two.
I blew it, didn't I?
Oops.
What did I do?
I swapped the wrong thing,
didn't I, here?
Ah-ha.
That is why I am not a
computer.
Good.
We should have swapped this
guy, right?
Swapped i plus 1,
right?
This was i.
We swap i plus 1,
good.
So, that's all wrong.
Let's swap the right things.
Now we have 6,
5, 3, 10, 8,
13, 2, 11.
That even corresponds to my
notes for some strange reason.
This is i and now this is j.
And now when I look,
I immediately have something
that is less than or equal to
the pivot.
We swap this and i plus 1,
so now we have 6,
5, 3, 2, 8, 13,
10, 11.
And we, at that point,
increment i to here.
And we have j now going here
and j runs to the end.
And the loop terminates.
When the loop terminates there
is one less swap that we do,
which is to put our pivot
element in the middle between
the two subarrays.
Here we swap this one and this
one, and so that gives us then
2, 5, 3, 6, 8,
13, 10, 11.
And this is the pivot.
And everything over here is
less than or equal to the pivot.
greater than or equal to the
pivot.
OK, so the quicksort routine.
Once we have this partition
routine, quicksort is a pretty
easy piece of code to write.
I should have said return here
i, right?
You have got to return with the
pivot.
Here I have got to return i
because we want to know where
the pivot element is.
Sorry.
I will plug in my code.
r gets partition of (A,
p, q) and then we quicksort (A,
p, r-1) and quicksort of (A,
r+1, q).
And that is it.
That's the code.
The initial call is quicksort
of (A, 1, n).
Because once we partitioned,
we just have to quicksort the
two portions,
the left and right portions.
Just the boundary case is
probably worth mentioning for a
second.
If there are zero or one
elements, that is basically what
can possibly happen here,
is that I get zero or one
elements here.
Then the point is there is
nothing to do because the array
is sorted, either because it is
an empty array or because it
only has one element.
One of the tricks to making
quicksort go fast,
as one tunes this,
is to, in fact,
look at having a special
purpose sorting routine for
small numbers of elements.
For example,
if you get down to five
elements having some straight
line piece of code that knows
how to sort five elements
sufficiently as opposed to
continuing to go through
recursion in order to accomplish
that.
And there are a variety of
other things.
This is a tail recursive code,
and so you can use certain tail
recursion optimizations.
And there are a variety of
other kinds of optimizations
that you can use to make this
code go fast.
So, yeah, you can tune it up a
bit beyond what is there,
but the core of it is this
efficient partitioning routine.
That is the algorithm.
It turns out that looking at
how fast it runs is actually a
little bit challenging.
In the analysis,
we are going to assume that all
elements are distinct.
It turns out that this
particular code does not work
very well when you have repeated
elements, but Hoare's original
partitioning routine is actually
more efficient in that case if
there are duplicates in what you
are sorting.
And I encourage you to look at
that.
It has a much more complicated
invariant for partitioning
routine, but it does a similar
kind of thing.
It's just a bit more
complicated.
If they weren't all distinct,
there are things you can do to
make them distinct or you can
just use this code.
The easiest thing to do is just
use Hoare's original code
because that works pretty well
when they are nondistinct.
But this is a little bit easier
to understand.
Let's let T(n) be the
worst-case running time on n
elements.
And so what is the worse-case?
What is the worse-case going to
be for quicksort?
That's right.
If you always pick the pivot
and everything is greater than
or everything is less than,
you are not going to partition
the array very well.
And when does that happen?
What does the original input
look like that makes that
happen?
If it is already sorted or
reverse sorted.
So, if the input is sorted or
That is actually kind of
important to understand,
because it turns out the most
common thing to sort is
something that is already
sorted, surprisingly,
or things that are nearly
sorted.
But often it is just sorted and
somebody wants to make sure it
is sorted.
Well, let's just sort it again
rather than checking to see if
it is sorted.
And, in those cases,
one side of the partition of
each partition has no elements.
Then we can write out what the
recursion is for that.
We have T(n).
If one side has no elements,
we are going to have T(0) on
that side.
And on the other side we are
going to have T(n-1).
We are just writing out the
recursion for this.
One side has no elements.
The other side has n-1
elements.
And then partitioning and all
the bookkeeping and so forth is
order n.
What is T(0)?
What is that asymptotically?
It's a constant,
order 1.
That is just order 1 + T(n-1) +
order n.
Well, the order 1 can be
absorbed into the order n,
so this is really just saying
it is T(n-1) + order n.
And what is that equal to?
That is order n^2.
Why is that order n^2?
It is an arithmetic series.
Actually, just like we got for
insertion sort.
Just like for insertion sort it
is an arithmetic series.
Going through all that work and
we have an algorithm called
quicksort, and it is no faster
than insertion sort.
Nevertheless,
I said it was a good algorithm.
The reason it is a good
algorithm is because its average
case time, as we are going to
see, is very good.
But let's try to understand
this a little bit more just so
that we understand the
difference between what is going
to happen in the average case
and what is going to happen in
the worse-case.
Let's draw a recursion tree for
this for T(n) = T(0) + T(n-1) +
and I will make the constant
explicit for cn.
So, we get an intuition of what
is going on.
Some constant times n.
And then we have T(n) is equal
to, and we write it with the
constant part here,
cn, and then T(0) here,
and then T(n-1) here.
Now, I know that all you folks
are really fast and want to jump
immediately to the full-blown
tree.
But, let me tell you,
my advice is that you spend
just a couple of minutes writing
it out.
Since the tree grows
exponentially,
it only costs you a constant
overhead to write out the small
cases and make sure that you
have got the pattern that you
are developing.
So, I am going to go one more
step.
Here we have T(0) and now this
becomes c(n-1) and now we have
another T(0) over here and
T(n-2).
And we continue that,
dot, dot, dot.
That is all equal to cn with a
T(0) here, c(n-1) with a T(0),
c(n-2), T(0) here,
and that goes all the way down
until we end up with T(1) down
here.
What is the height of this tree?
What is the height of the tree
here?
Yeah, n.
Good.
Because every step we are just
decrementing the argument by 1.
So, the height is n.
To analyze this,
let's first add up everything
that is here.
Just so we understand where
these things are coming from,
this is just theta of the
summation of k equals 1 to n of
k, actually of ck.
That is what is in there.
And that is equal to order n^2.
That is where our algorithmatic
series is coming from.
So, that is Theta(n^2).
And then all of these things
here are all Theta(1).
And how many of them are there?
There are n Theta(1)'s.
So, the total amount is T(n) =
Theta(n) + Theta(n^2) =
Theta(n^2).
Just to see what the structure
is in terms of the recursion
tree, it is a highly unbalanced
recursion tree.
Now I am going to do something
that I told you should never do,
which is we are going to be do
a best-case analysis.
This is for intuition only.
And, in general,
we don't do best-case analyses.
It doesn't mean anything,
unless we get some intuition
for it maybe.
But basically it means nothing
mathematically because it's
providing no guarantee.
And so this is intuition only.
If we are really lucky what
happens for partition?
What is going to be the lucky
case?
Yeah, it splits right in the
middle.
Which is essentially --
-- n/2 : n/2.
It is really (n-1)/2 :
(n-1)/2, but we're not going to
worry about the details because
we're only doing intuition for
the best-case because best-case
is not what we want.
If that happened,
what is the recurrence I get?
Imagine it split it exactly in
the middle every time,
then what happens?
You get T(n) = 2T(n/2) + order
n for partitioning and
bookkeeping.
And what is the solution of
that recurrence?
That is n log n.
That is the same as the merge
sort recurrence.
It is which case of the master
theorem?
Case 2, right?
Because n to the log base 2 of
2 is n to the 1,
it is the same,
so we tack on the extra log n.
Case 2 of the master theorem.
That is pretty good.
That says that in the best-case
quicksort is going to do well.
How about let's suppose the
split is always let's say 1/10 :
9/10, 1/10n :
9/10n.
In that case,
are we lucky or are we unlucky?
I mean, if the split is really
skewed, we clearly are going to
be unlucky, right,
because then it's,
say, 1 to n.
If it is really in the middle
it is n log n.
What do you suppose it is if it
is 1/10 : 9/10?
Is that lucky or unlucky?
We will have a little democracy
here.
Who thinks that that is a lucky
case?
It is going to be fast running
time.
And who thinks it is an unlucky
case?
OK, so we have some brave
souls.
And who didn't vote?
Oh, come on.
Come on.
It is always better,
by the way, to say yes or no
and be right or wrong,
because then you have some
emotional commitment to it and
we will remember better,
rather than just sitting and
being quiet.
You don't manipulate your own
emotions well enough to remember
things well.
Those people who voted win over
the people who don't vote,
whether they are right or
wrong.
Well, let's take a look.
Here is the recurrence.
T(n) = T(1/10n) + T(9/10n) +
Theta(n).
And we will assume that this
part here is less than or equal
to some cn in order to analyze
it.
We will just do a recursion
tree for this and see.
Here is a recursion tree.
We have T(n) = cn,
T(1/10n), T(9/10n).
Now we have again cn at the
top.
This gets complicated,
right?
This is 1/10cn.
Now, over here we have 1/10.
And then we are plugging it
into the recursion again,
so we now get T(1/100n) and
over here we get T(9/100n).
And over here we have now
9/10cn.
And that gives us T(9/100n)
again.
And here we get T(81/100n).
And we keep going on.
That is equal to cn,
1/10cn here.
Down this way we have 1/100cn.
And that keeps going down until
we get to order 1 down here.
And over here we have 9/10cn.
And here, let's see,
this is 9/100cn and this is now
9/100cn and this is 81/100cn.
And these things keep going
down until they get down to
order 1.
But the leaves are not all at
uniform depth here,
right?
This side is way further up
than this side,
right?
Because here we are only going
down by 9/10 each time.
So, in fact,
what is the length of this path
here?
What is the length of this path
down to this,
if I take the left most spine?
Somebody raise there hand.
Yeah?
Log base 10 of n.
Because I am basically cutting
down by a factor of 10 each
time.
And how long does it take me to
reduce it to 1?
That is the definition,
if you will,
of what a log is,
log base 10.
What is this one?
What is this path going that
way?
Log of n. Log base 10/9 of n.
Because we're going down by
9/10 each time.
Once again, essentially the
definition of n.
And everything in between there
is somewhere between log base 10
of n and log base 10/9 of n.
So, everything is in between
there.
Now what I can do is do the
trick that we did for mergesort
in looking at what the
evaluation of this is by adding
up what is the cost of the total
level.
That is just cn.
What is the cost of the next
level?
cn.
And what is the cost of the
next level?
cn.
Every level we are still doing
the same amount of work.
And we take that all the way
down.
And the last levels --
Eventually we hit some point
where it is not equal to cn
where we start getting things
that are less than or equal to
cn because some of the leaves
start dropping out starting at
this level.
Basically this part is going to
be log base 10 of n,
and then we start getting
things that are less than or
equal to cn, and so forth,
until finally we get to add it
all up.
T(n) is going to be less than
or equal to cn times,
well, what is the longest that
this could possibly be?
Log base 10/9 of n.
Plus we have all of the leaves
that we have to add in,
but all the leaves together add
up to just order n.
All the leaves add up to order
n, so we have + Theta(n).
And so this is how much?
If I add all of this together,
what is this asymptotically?
That is n log n.
So, T(n) is actually bounded by
n log n.
We are lucky.
Those people who guessed lucky
were right.
A 1/10 : 9/10 split is
asymptotically as good as a 50 :
50 split.
And, in fact,
we can lower bound this by just
looking at these things here and
discover that,
in fact, T(n) is lower bounded
by cn log base 10 of n + order
n.
And so T(n) is lower bounded by
also asymptotically n log n.
So, T(n) is actually Theta(n lg
n).
Now, this is not really proof.
I generally recommend that you
don't do this kind of thing to
do a proof.
This is a good intuition of a
recursion tree.
The way you prove this is what?
Substitution method.
Good.
What you do is use this to get
your guess and then use
substitution method to prove
that your guess is right.
It is too easy to make mistakes
with this method.
It is very easy to make
mistakes.
With the substitution method it
is harder to make mistakes
because there is just algebra
there that you are cranking
through.
It is easier to verify rather
than dot, dot,
dots and trees that you drew
improperly and wrote in wrong
amounts and so forth.
OK?
So, this is n log n.
That's pretty good.
It is order n log n.
And we are lucky.
Now let's try another one.
This is all for intuition
because, I will tell you,
by the time we get to the end
of this class you folks are
going to bolting for the door
because we are going to do some
good math today,
actually.
It is actually fun math,
I think, but it is challenging.
If you are not awake,
you can still sleep now,
but I will tell you when to
wake up.
One more bit of intuition.
Suppose that we alternate
steps.
Suppose we do the partitioning
thing.
And it happens that we start
out lucky and then we have a
partitioning step that is
unlucky and then we have a step
that is lucky and a step that is
unlucky and we do that all the
way down the tree.
Suppose we alternate.
Are we lucky or unlucky if we
do that?
This time I want everybody
voting.
It doesn't matter what your
answer is.
Everybody has to have a stake
in the game.
It is sort of like horseracing.
If ever you have watched
horseracing, it is really
boring, but if you put a little
bit of money down,
a little skin in the game
suddenly it is interesting.
The same thing here.
I want everybody to put some
skin in the game.
Who thinks that this is going
to be lucky?
Who thinks it is going to be
unlucky?
OK.
Who didn't vote?
[LAUGHTER] You guys.
No skin in the game,
ha?
Let's analyze this so we can
once again write a recurrence.
On the lucky step,
we will have L(n) be the
running time on a lucky step of
size n.
And that is going to be twice.
While the next step is going to
be unlucky.
It is two unluckies over 2 plus
order n.
That is our lucky step.
And then for the unlucky step
it is essentially going to be L
of n minus 1,
it is going to be lucky on the
next step, plus order n.
That is unlucky.
See how I have described this
behavior with a system now of
recurrences that are dependent
where the boundary cases,
once again which are unstated,
is that the recurrences have a
constant solution with constant
input.
Now we just do a little bit of
algebra using substitution.
L(n) is then equal to,
well, I can just plug in,
for U(n/2) plug in the value of
U(n/2).
And that gives me 2[L(n/2-1) +
Theta(n) + Theta(n)].
See what I did here?
I simply plugged in,
for U(n/2), this recurrence.
In fact, technically I guess I
should have said Theta(n/2) just
to make this substitution more
straightforward.
It is the same thing,
but just to not skip a step.
That we can now crank through.
And that is 2L(n/2 - 1) +,
and now I have two T(n/2) plus
another one, so all of that is
just order n.
And what is the solution to
that recurrence?
n log n.
Theta(n lg n).
Does everybody see that?
OK?
Theta(n lg n).
This is basically just,
once again, master theorem with
a little bit of jiggering here.
That minus one is only going to
help us, actually,
in the solution of the master
theorem.
So, it is order n lg n.
We are lucky.
If we alternate lucky and
unlucky, we are lucky.
How can we insure that we are
usually lucky?
If I have the input already
sorted, I am going to be
unlucky.
Excuse me?
You could randomly arrange the
elements, that is one way.
What is another way?
That is a perfectly good way,
actually.
In fact, it is a common thing
to do.
Randomly choose the pivot,
OK.
It turns out those are
effectively equivalent,
but we are going to do the
randomly choose the pivot
because it is a little bit
easier to analyze.
But they are effectively
equivalent.
That gives us the algorithm
called randomized quicksort.
And the nice thing about
randomized quicksort is that the
running time is independent of
the input ordering.
Very much for the same reason
that if I just scramble the
input, it would be independent
of the input ordering.
If I randomly scramble the
input then it doesn't matter
what the order of the input was.
Whereas, original quicksort has
some slow cases,
input sorted or reverse sorted,
and some fast cases.
In particular,
it turns out that if it is
random it is going to be pretty
fast.
If I actually randomly scramble
the input or pivot on a random
element, it doesn't matter what
the input was.
One way of thinking about this
is with an adversary.
Imagine your adversary,
you are saying I have a good
sorting algorithm and he says I
have a good sorting algorithm
and you're trying to sell to a
single customer.
And the customer says OK,
you guys come up with
benchmarks for each of your
algorithms.
And you get to look at his
algorithm.
Well, you look and you say oh,
he is using quicksort.
I will just give him something
that is already sorted.
That is what you could do to
him.
If you had quicksort,
he would do the same thing to
you.
So, how can you defeat him?
Well, one way is with
randomization.
Big idea in computer science,
use random numbers.
The idea here is if I permute
the ordering at random,
as one suggestion,
or I pivot at random places,
then the input ordering didn't
matter.
And so there is no bad ordering
that he can provide that is
going to make my code run
slowly.
Now, I might get unlucky.
But that is just unlucky in my
use of my random-number
generator.
It is not unlucky with respect
to what the input was.
What the input was doesn't
matter.
Everybody follow that?
OK.
The nice thing about randomized
quicksort is that it makes no
assumptions about the input
distribution.
You don't have to assume that
all inputs are equally likely
because either you can make it
that way or you pivot in a way
that makes that effectively
whole.
And, in particular,
there is no specific input that
can elicit the worst-case
behavior.
The worst-case is determined
only by a random-number
generator.
And, therefore,
since it is only determined by
a random-number generator,
we can essentially bound the
unluckiness mathematically.
We can say what are the odds?
So, we are going to analyze
this.
And this is where you know if
you belong in this course or
not.
If you have skipped 6.042 or
whatever, this is a good place
to do the comparison.
Since it is going to be a
little bit, why don't people
just stand up for a moment and
take a stretch break.
Since this is going to be a
nice piece of mathematics we are
going to do, you are going to
want to feel fresh for it.
Stretch break is over.
Analysis.
Good.
I think we are going to make
this.
I am sort of racing.
There is a lot of stuff to
cover today.
Good.
Let's let T(n) now be the
random variable for the running
time assuming --
Wow.
I didn't even write here what
we did here.
So, we are going to pivot on a
random element.
That is the basic scheme we are
going to do.
And the way I do that,
by the way, is just in the code
for partition,
rather than partitioning on the
first element,
before I do the partition,
I just swap the first element
with some other element in the
array chosen at random,
perhaps itself.
So, they are all equally likely
to be pivoted on.
And then just run the ordinary
partition.
This is a random variable for
running in time assuming,
we have to make an assumption
for doing probability,
the random numbers are
independent.
So that when I pivot in one
place, it is independent of how
I pivoted in some other place as
I am running this algorithm.
Then, to analyze this,
what I am going to do is I want
to know where we pivoted.
For k = 0, 1,
..., n-1, let's let,
for a particular partition,
the random variable X_k = 1 if
partition generates a k :
n-k-1 split,
and 0 otherwise.
In the partition routine,
I am picking a random element
to pivot on.
And X_k is going to be my
random variable that is 1 if it
generates a split that has k
elements on the left side and
n-k-1 elements on the right side
of the pivot.
Some of those,
too, of course are n-1 because
I also have the pivot.
And 0 otherwise.
So, I now have n random
variables that I have defined
associated with a single
partition where all of them are
going to be zero except one of
them, whichever one happens to
occur is going to have the value
1.
This is called,
by the way.
What is the name of this type
of random variable?
Bernoulli.
Well, Bernoulli has other
assumptions.
It is an indicator random
variable.
It turns out it is Bernoulli,
but that's OK.
It is an indicator random
variable.
It just takes on the value of
0, 1.
And Bernoulli random variables
are a particular type of
indicator random variable.
Which it turns out these are.
That is an indicator random
variable.
Indicator random variables are
a good way when you are trying
to understand what the sum of a
bunch of things is.
It is a good way to break apart
your big random variables into
smaller ones that can be
analyzed.
Let's just take a look at this
indicator random variable.
What is the expectation of X_k
equal to?
In other words,
what is the probability that I
generate a k :
n-k-1 split?
X_k is, let's just write out
what that means,
just to refresh people's
memory.
That is 0 times the probability
that X_k equals 0 plus 1 times
the probability that X_k equals
1, which is equal,
well, that is all zero.
That is just equal to the
probability that X_k equals 1.
And that is a general property
of indicator random variables,
is that their expectation is
the probability that they are 1.
The nice thing about indicator
random variables is it directly
connects the probability to the
expectation without any other
terms going on.
What is the probability of X_k
equals 1?
1/n.
So, all splits are equally
likely.
And I have n elements,
so each ones has a 1/n chance
of being picked as the pivot.
And, once you pick the pivot,
that determines what is on the
left and the right and so forth.
So, it is 1/n.
Everybody with me so far?
More or less?
OK.
As I say, this is going to test
whether you're in the class.
If you go home and you study
this and you cannot get it,
and you have a deficiency in
your math background in trying
to take the course,
this is a good indication that
probably you have taken
something a little over your
head.
Let's write out what T(n) is
equal to here.
T(n) is going to be equal to
T(0) + T(n-1) + Theta(n) if we
get a 0 : n-1 split and is equal
to T(1) + T(n-2) + order n if we
have a 1 : n-2 split.
And now down here it is going
to be T(n-1) + T(0) + Theta(n)
if we end up with an n-1 :
0 split.
So, this is our recurrence for
T(n).
And, unfortunately,
the recurrence is kind of hairy
because it has got n cases.
And this is,
once again, where the
brilliance of being able to use
indicator random variables comes
in.
Because we will be able to take
this case analysis and reduce it
to mathematics so we don't have
cases using indicator random
variables.
And the way we do that is using
the following trick of
converting the cases into a
summation.
Let's just take a look at why
these two things are the same.
The indicator random variable
is zero, except if you get the
particular split.
Therefore, this summation is
going to be zero,
except for that k which
actually appeared in which case
it is the value that we say it
is.
See the trick using
multiplication by 0,
1 variable to handle all the
cases?
I think that is damn clever.
And this is like the classic
thing that you do with indicator
random variables.
It's one of the reasons they
are a very powerful method.
Because now we actually have a
mathematical expression,
hairy although it may be,
for our recurrence.
Now, what we are going to
analyze is the expected value of
T(n).
That is what we want to do.
What is the expected value of
T(n)?
To do that, I just write the
expected value of T(n) is equal
to the expected value of this
big summation.
And now we can go ahead and
start to evaluate the expected
value of that summation.
Everybody with me?
Yes?
Any questions at this point?
I see a thumbs up.
That's nice to see.
But I generally believe that
what I want to see is no thumbs
down.
It is good to see the thumbs
up, but that means one person
understands, or thinks he
understands.
[LAUGHTER] So,
this is, I claim,
equal to the following.
Actually, I am going to need a
little space here so I am going
to move the equal sign over a
little bit.
I claim that summation is equal
to that.
This expectation is equal to
that summation of expectations.
Why is that?
What are the magic words that
justify this step?
Linearity of expectation.
The expectation of a sum is the
sum of the expectations.
So, that is linearity of
expectation.
I don't need independence for
that.
That is just always true for
expectation of any random
variables.
The sum of the expectations is
the expectation of the sum and
vice versa.
Here we did the vice versa.
That is equal to now the sum of
k=0 to n-1 of expectation of X_k
[T(k) + T(n-k-1) + Theta(n)].
Why is that true?
What I have done is I've said
the expectation of the product
is the product of the
expectations.
That is because of
independence.
What is independent of what?
The X_k here,
random variable,
are independent of any of the
other partitionings in,
if you will,
the X_k that would exist for
any of the other recursive
calls.
So, whatever happens in here is
independent of what happened
there.
We are actually hiding.
Since we have a recurrence,
we are not partitioning the
same wage time.
We have a different one.
We actually have something
going on underneath the
mathematics you have to pay
attention to that the
mathematics alone isn't really
showing, which is that in T(k)
there is actually a set of
random choices that are being
made, if you will.
And so you have to understand
that those are independent of
those, in which case we can
multiple the probabilities of
their expectations.
Is everybody with me?
That is a big one,
independence of X_k from other
random choices.
That is equal to now,
well, first of all,
this is nice.
What is the expectation of X_k?
1/n.
That actually doesn't even
belong in the summation.
We will just pop it outside.
I get 1/n times the sum of k=0
to n-1 of expectation of T(k) +
1/n summation k=0 to n-1 of
expectation of T(n-k-1) + 1/n
summation k=0 to n-1 up to
Theta(n).
That is, again,
using linearity of expectation
there this time to split up
these pieces and just factoring
out the expectation of k as
being 1/n.
Everybody with me still?
All of this is elementary.
It is just one of these things
that is hard just because there
are so many steps.
And it takes that you have seen
some of this before.
Now the next observation is
that these two summations are,
in fact, identical.
They are the same summation,
just in a different order.
This is going T(0),
T(1), T(2), T(3) up to T(n-1).
This one is going T(n-1),
T(n-2), T(n-3) down to T(0).
These are, in fact,
equal.
So, therefore,
I have two of them.
And then what is this term
equal to?
What is that one equal to?
Theta(n).
Let's just see why.
The summation of 0 :
n of Theta(n) is Theta(n^2)
divided by n.
Or, if I want to bring the
Theta(n) out,
I have 1 times the summation of
k equals1 to n of Theta(1) or of
1.
So, once again,
you get n, either way of doing
it.
This is, in some sense,
because the summations have
identical terms,
and this is just algebra.
Now what we are going to do is
do something for technical
convenience.
Because we are going to absorb
the k=0, 1 terms into the
Theta(n) for technical
convenience.
We have a recurrence here where
I have an order n.
And, if I look at the cases
where k=0 or k=1,
I know what the expectation is.
For 0, 1, the expected cost is
the worst case cost,
which is constant.
Because I am only solving the
problem for a constant size.
And we know that for any of the
boundary cases that our solution
of recurrence,
our assumption is that it is
constant time.
So, I basically can just take
those two terms out.
And all that does it accumulate
some more constant here in the
Theta(n).
It is going to make the
solution of the recurrence a
little bit easier.
And, if I do that,
I get expectation of T(n) = 2/n
summation k=2 to n-1 of
expectation of T(k) + Theta(n).
So, all of that work was to
derive the recurrence.
And now we have to solve it.
Just to review what we did,
we started out with a
recurrence which was for the
random variable which involved a
case statement.
We converted that into some
mathematics without the case
statement, just with a product,
and then we derived a
recurrence for the expectation.
And now we are in the process
of trying to solve that
recurrence.
We have done some
simplification of the recurrence
so that we understand what it is
that we are going to solve here.
By the way, I don't give things
like this on quizzes.
I do expect you to understand
it.
The elements of this you will
find on a quiz.
This is a lot of work to figure
out.
This took smart people to do.
Even though it is all
elementary, but working out
something like this at the
elementary level is still a bit
of work even for somebody who is
knowledgeable in this area.
Now we are going to solve that
last recurrence over there and
we are going to prove that the
expectation of T(n) is less than
or equal to (an lg n) for some
constant a greater than 0.
That is going to be what we are
going to do.
And so what technique do you
think we should use to prove
this?
Does this look like a master
method?
It is nothing like the master
method.
So, when in doubt do
substitution.
It is the grand-daddy of all
methods.
What we will do is solve the
base case by simply choosing a
big enough so that (an lg n) is
bigger than the expectation of
T(n) for sufficiently large
small n.
So, I just pick a to be big
enough.
And this is,
by the way, why I wanted to
exclude 0 and 1 from the
recurrence.
Because, for example,
when n=0, log of 0 is,
it's like dividing by 0,
right, you cannot do it.
Log of 1 is 0.
So here, even if I restricted
it to 1, here I would have a 0,
and I can't ever pick a big
enough to dominate those cases.
What I do is I just say look,
I just absorb whatever the cost
is into the T(n) for technical
convenience.
And that lets me address it as
(an lg n) to be big enough to
handle the base case.
So, that is why we made that
technical assumption.
We are going to use a fact
which is that the summation of
k=2 to n-1 of k lg k is less
than or equal to 1/2n^2 lg n -
1/8n^2.
I am going to leave that as an
exercise for you to workout.
I think it is an exercise in
the book, too.
I want you to go and evaluate
this.
There are two ways to evaluate
it.
One is by using purely
summations and facts about
summations by splitting the
summation into two pieces and
reconstituting it to prove this
bound.
The other way is to use the
integral method for solving
summations.
Either way you can prove.
The integral method actually
gets you a tighter bound than
this.
This is a basic fact,
and you should go off and know
how to do that.
Now let's do substitution.
The expectation of T(n) is less
than or equal to 2/n times the
summation k=2 to n-1,
now we do the substitution of
ak lg k, the smaller values plus
Theta(n).
I might mentioned,
by the way, that the hard part
of doing this,
it is easy to get the bound
without this term,
it is easy to get this bound,
1/2n^2 lg n,
it is harder to get the second
order term.
It turns out you need the
second order term in order to do
what we are going to do.
You have to be able to subtract
a quadratic amount of the n^2 lg
n in order to make this proof
work.
And that is the trickier part
in evaluating that summation.
So, we get this.
That is less than or equal to?
Well, I happen to know how much
this is by using that formula.
I use my fact and get 2a/n
(1/2n^2 lg n - 1/8n^2) +
Theta(n).
Did I do something wrong?
There we go.
Very good.
That is equal to -
If I multiply this first part
through that is an lg n.
And now, so I don't make a
mistake, I want to express this
as my desired,
this is what I want it to be,
minus a residual.
I am going to write the
residual as this part.
And so, the way to write that
is, that is going to be minus.
And then it is going to be this
term here, which is going to be
an/4 - Theta(n).
And that is going to be less
than or equal to an lg n if this
part is positive.
And I can make that part
positive by picking a big enough
such that an/4 dominates the
constant in the Theta(n) here.
Whatever the constant is here,
I can find an a that is big
enough so that this term makes
this part positive.
If a is big enough so that an/4
dominates Theta(n).
And so the running time of
randomized quicksort is order n
lg n.
That is what we just proved,
the expected running time is
order n lg n.
Now, in practice,
quicksort is a great algorithm.
It is typically three or more
times faster than mergesort.
It doesn't give you the strong
guarantee necessarily of
mergesort and being worst-case n
lg n.
But in practice,
if you use randomized
quicksort, it is generally as
much as three times faster.
It does require code tuning in
order to get it up to be that
fast.
You do have to go and coarsen
the base cases and do some other
tricks there,
but most good sorting
algorithms that you will find
are based on quicksort.
Also one of the other reasons
it works well is because it
tends to work well with caches
in virtual memory.
We are not really talking much
about caching models and so
forth, big topic these days in
algorithms, but it does work
very well with caches in virtual
memory.
It is another reason that this
is a good algorithm to use.
Good recitation,
by the way, on Friday.
We are going to see another n
log n time algorithm,
a very important one in
recitation on Friday.